welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Deadpool 3 has an official
first look from set photos from the
film's production near Pinewood Studios
in the UK and there's so much to take
away from Ryan Reynolds new costume and
other visual Clues from these images so
let's break down the latest updates from
Deadpool 3 and his coming team up with
Wolverine and the X-Men by the way new
rockstars is now a network with three
channels this main channel for Easter
egg breakdowns the Deep dive for special
film analyzes from me and the break room
where you can find our secret Invasion
after show inside Marvel subscribe to
all three and support our network with
some merch from nerdright.shop this
morning Hugh Jackman Finally Revealed
images of himself in his new yellow suit
alongside Deadpool shortly after the
film's official account released a
high-res version of the image and it
looks so good finally a comic accurate
yellow suit that the 2000 X-Men movie
mocked you actually go outside Mason
what would you prefer yellow spandex now
we still have not seen Wolverine's mask
and this suit has sleeves and based off
of how jacked Jackman is getting for
this movie you just know will Maureen's
gonna get some mockery for this and use
those adamantium claws to shred these
sleeves off Deadpool 3 is currently in
the midst of production in the UK a
second unit production set to take place
in Vancouver in Canada production is
moving swiftly likely due to the threat
of the actors Union going on strike
along with the writer's Guild a
negotiation deadline for the actors
pushed to July 12th but I will remind
everyone that Ryan Reynolds and his crew
shot the first Deadpool film in 2016. in
less than eight weeks so these guys like
to work fast and they'll likely move
even faster since due to the writer
strike Ryan Reynolds is not allowed to
ad-lib or to improvise because that
would constitute writing and then may
plan to do ADR pickup lines for this
third movie later after the writer
strike comes to an end hopefully with a
better deal for the writers and since
Deadpool is often masked with his mouth
covered audio pickups and punch-ups
would be especially easy now on Friday
The Hollywood Reporter confirmed that
Jennifer Garner is returning to play
elextra in Deadpool 3 seemingly
confirming many of the other surprise
returns from the fox Marvel era that we
have been hearing about in another video
recently I broke down all the rumors of
the cast in this movie which made
include Halle Berry returning to storm
Patrick Stewart returning as Professor X
Ben Affleck returning his Daredevil
James Marsden Ian McKellen Famke Jansen
and others from the fox Marvel titles in
the 2000s Owen Wilson has been spotted
in London where the movie is shooting
and there are even rumors of Channing
Tatum shooting a cameo as Gambit for now
take all these rumors with a grain of
salt but a plot that involves the time
variance Authority from Loki suggests
multiple timelines and Alternate
realities and Marvel moved up this
movie's release date to May 3rd 2024
while pushing all other movies back so
it's increasingly looking like Kevin
feige sees it as an essential Money
Maker the latest rumors are that Matthew
mcfadian will be playing the TVA agent
named Paradox and then Emma Corin
confirmed to be playing a villain in
this movie will be a TVA judge with a
rank and roll similar to Justice
rensslayer with Loki season 2 coming to
Disney plus this October and a trailer
likely to drop any day now there's a
good chance we meet these characters in
Loki season 2. but when you look at
these set photos the first thing that
jumps out is a more vibrant color of
Ryan Reynolds new Deadpool suit the 2016
and 2018 film by comparison heavily
desaturated Deadpool for a Dusty or
dirtier look befitting his rebellious
nature and his R-rated humor do you need
energy do you need it now that's a job
for one shot
one shot Energy Chews are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
everybody really one shot makes energy
choose and focus shoes so that you can
choose if you want to rev up or Zone in
each energy chew has 75 milligrams of
pure caffeine plus 600 milligrams of
additional neurotropics that give you a
serious energy boost that works
immediately as you chew the Focus Shoes
come in new rockstars themed packaging
we use them all the time to get a
natural boost of focus and energy with B
C D and E vitamins plus zinc to help
with immune system support and the amino
acid tyrosine both energy to choose and
focus shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals get
started with one shot energy today by
going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off your order now
these are just photos taken of the actor
on set who knows what it will look like
in the trailer footage and in the final
film after it's gone through coloring
and to be clear Defender actor Karen
Sony has been shooting his scenes and he
confirmed Deadpool 3 freeze humor and
violence haven't been toned down at all
and that this third film will still be
very much R-rated but it is possible
that this new suit has pumped up its
Vibrance and saturation to make it look
especially good on screen opposite from
a yellow suit furthering the speculation
that Wolverine in this movie will suit
up in his classic yellow and black suit
like the one that we've seen in those
wolverine 3 teaser photos that never
ended up getting used this prop was
created by James Mangold and shot for a
deleted scene for the 2013 The Wolverine
as a bit of fan service in case the
studio wanted to suit up Wolverine that
way for the next film this was long
before mangled refocused that next film
into the 2017 Logan film which was of
course the somber Western in the style
of Unforgiven director Sean Levy and
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman and James
Mangold have all suggested that Deadpool
3 will not touch the events of the 2017
Logan film or change Logan's death in
that film at all but we will see what
that promise means exactly like Deadpool
3 could visit an alternate timeline
Death of Wolverine set in a similar
setting as a different Wolverine is
helping some kids Rush across the
Canadian border to deliver them to the
members of the alpha flight or something
like that I bring it up because these
set photos depict a scene in a woodland
setting with a forest floor similar to
that final battle in Logan and there
have been unconfirmed reports of a chase
scene with Deadpool and multiple TVA
agents in the forest there have also
been unconfirmed rumors and theories
that this movie will take place in an
alternate House of m-style universe with
Elizabeth Olsen coming back as the
Scarlet Witch and mutant kind led by a
Victorious Ian McKellen Magneto and
Wolverine leading a mutant resistance
group we'll see but it could be one of
many Fox Marvel timelines that we see in
Deadpool 3 other than the vibrancy the
suit does look mostly the same
especially in the shots where Reynolds
is wearing his utility belt like the
fabric is less segmented less marred by
cuts and bullet holes but it has the
same black shoulder pads and straps one
difference is that rather than the black
buckles on the straps there are hints of
brass Clips matching the gold color now
on his gloves many are also focusing on
the mystery figure sitting in the back
seat of this van with an unusual red
helmet and mask before you jump to any
conclusions that this is a Magneto
helmet or a Scarlet Witch headgear I
think this is just the Deadpool mask
with the eyepiece is removed and this
may be Ryan Reynolds stunt double while
they have a practical version of the
Deadpool mask with the black eye pieces
and the white eyes for close-ups they
often do subtle VFX on Deadpool's eyes
to animate them so that they're more
emotive kind of like a bugs money Style
cartoon but I want to know from you
would you like to see Deadpool and
Deadpool 3 revisit the ultimate timeline
events of the ending of Logan but with
Wolverine in an alternate yellow suit or
should Deadpool steer clear of any
version of that final battle because it
is sacred let me know in the comments
below and support us with a shirt like
our secret Invasion inspired shirts at
nerd riot.shop you can follow me on
Instagram Twitter eavos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]